[Music]
hey guys Oh assume of course she's
comers but anyway I have realized it's
been a minute since I've made a video
where I've been myself for you instead
of curated content all my dreams I mean
I'm myself in live students I'm gonna
cut my hair one thing I like to do in
the morning if I want to be productive
is write down my tasks for the day I try
to do this every day but then it started
to be something that I would beat myself
up over if I didn't do every day but
that is journaling and now I've kind of
gotten to the point where I realize I
don't have to journal every day just
like when I need to I feel like it
that's okay this is if it's something
that you've just like to do for you
don't beat yourself up father if you
don't want to do it every single day
like that no one else is going to
benefit or not from it so if it's not
benefiting you then why why should you
feel like yeah
[Music]
okay scissors scissors I got some
brownies sugar
supposed to be like ready to cut your
hair straight out so we'll see yeah I'm
gonna watch a YouTube video on how to
cut my hair and then I'm gonna cut my
hair three different camera angles going
here so
see how is I am out fights nobody worry
about I'm probably gonna have to do a
voiceover for this here has quick
warning this was an absolute mess and
took me a couple hours to do what I
basically tried to do was create a
triangle in the front of my head and
that would be the French
[Music]
well done Yasmine you cut off a piece of
your hair ten out of ten what I would
try to do is cut it in an angle I would
get the longer pieces that were on the
sides of my head and cut them longer
than the fringe pieces in the center of
my head one interesting thing that I
found though is that I couldn't see for
a lot of it I shouldn't have done this
in the wind but the fact that I had
quite long hair and I was trying to
section it to keep the fringe in front
of my face meant that I couldn't see the
YouTube videos that I was watching
okay I'm just gonna go look this is not
a how-to video so I'm sorry if it
doesn't make sense
[Music]
one more tip that I learned from
watching YouTube it is was to cut
upwards into your fall fringe if you
have curly hair it looks more natural
and stops that kind of cut where it just
has gone too short it looks absolutely
terrible it
altum Utley I am a massive coward and it
took me far too long to do this but
hopefully it's in some way interesting
for you
[Music]
weird I can't get used to this weird I
don't know how I feel
hello I'm here is the big reveal do we
like it is it too weird I don't know is
it try I can't even tell he's different
definitely gonna take some getting used
to
I look pretty sophisticated yeah I think
it looks better when I have my hair up
one thing that I've always been really
bad at is change and that includes my
hair I've had the same hairdresser since
I was a child it's my mom's friend so
her and my mom would work as a team and
she would cut off my hair and my mom
would get the dustpan and brush and
quickly just brush it before I could see
around the floor because when my haircut
was finished I used to inspect the
ground to see how much hair was taking
off and it was too much I would cry it's
just been something that I've always
struggled with so being able to cut my
own hair into a freakin fringe which is
like so new for me
I'm proud well then I did it I did it
it's half 11 I think I might still have
time to get turnips and animal crossing
so I'm probably probably need some
cherries welcome to the workspace forget
that my bed is right there literally
walked two steps back
this is where I spent all day and then
all night playing The Witcher it's a
really cloudy day animal crossing today
so my outfit is a watermelon and I've
got a little snot dripping from my nose
am I too late
what to make a turnip woman okay I'll
save an end I'm gonna fill my mum and
see what she thinks about this yeah I
cut my hair do you like it yeah I think
I did quite a good job huh yeah it's
like it's kind of like yours
it just went it just puffs up as soon as
I cut it yeah I do actually
and it looks quite nice when I put it
when I put it up cuz it's like I can
like it's quite sophisticated wouldn't
put up and I don't look young either I
don't think I think I look the same age
really because I thought it would make
me look like 10 but I think I look like
the same age I still look 16
I just phoning you to get your reaction
on camera cause filming it I can flare
your face if you want me to
oh I've done something I've got a full
fringe I've never had this before do you
not think I look different now it's
getting hot in the cold ah well there
you go then
got the seal of approval from the mother
I thought this might be what her hair
looked like when she was younger about
parity I wasn't but she liked it she
said I look like a young Kate Bush and I
know the name but I cannot think of the
face so maybe that's all used to be
guide for my brother didn't think I'd
changed a bit so it is now Monday
morning I'm getting ready for work
but I just wanted to check in with you
because I don't think I actually did an
outro this is what she looks like in the
morning by the way the whole point of
that video was just to share another day
in my life with you I don't do them
right often because I always think that
I'd I'm not really doing that many
interesting things especially now but I
know it makes you feel closer to me and
I want to share that with you every now
and then do I have crusts on my lips no
okay cold so I'm gonna start my working
week from home I am very very lucky to
be able to do that I know that other
people haven't been able to a lot of
people have been laid off and I really
hope that you're doing well and I also
want to say thank you so much to
everyone that's been joining me in my
live streams we managed to raise five
hundred and ten pounds for black lives
matter which is amazing if you think
everyone deserves equality
then you stand for blacklivesmatter
because before you start to raise them
up how are we ever going to be equal
together it's not makes sense I mean
everyone's using that analogy of if one
house is burning you can't just say all
the houses matter that's exactly it it's
like we know where the injustice stands
we can see it it's being shown to us
it's it's the morning I'm trying to say
things I mean ultimately I am white and
I'll never 100% understand but that does
not mean that I can't talk out about it
and help in any way that I can and say
no this isn't right this [ __ ] isn't
right and we all deserve equality we
can't treat everyone equal and then get
equal we have to sort out the inequality
first and then okay cool everyone who is
speaking up everyone who is going
through hard times everyone who is
dealing with this in their own ways you
don't have to be like shouting that out
screaming loud there's loads of other
ways that you can help combat this I'll
put a link down in the description below
and I'm really sorry if this is coming
across as like nonsensical but I've long
had an issue with not wanting to offend
people and I think that's like the
English within me so yeah this is very
Ron T and I'm going to go now okay
have a lovely day or you've meant bye
[Applause]